[Music]
so everyone recovered from lunch already
so you're all awake
yeah then just dive into it so so who if
you deploy the model to production and
probably some of you use the text
classifier for something though and then
the normal way of things is like you get
a data set right you clean it you build
your model and you look at some metrics
think about like accuracy is probably
something or one precision to be high
and then you say like okay 90% nice put
it live yeah but I tell you this is
often not enough especially not for text
because you have messy data and it's
really easy really easy to get some
partial leakage in your data so for
example if you do email specification
and you have some people like we see an
example later some people like they do
resending all emails and you see like
okay in this class this happens a lot in
this data class then you have probably
good accuracy in this class but you're
not learning anything about your problem
but about your data set and it's
probably something you don't want
and it also like validation sets are
often not enough so can you see it or is
it hard to see okay so somebody Dacian
sets are often also not enough because
it's also something about your data you
have right now but your data might
change and especially for text you want
to make sure that the model you have in
production know something inherent of
your problem and not only about the
specific data you have there so you
probably want to know more about your
model and your metrics and your
validation scores so but it's another
thing yeah what is a black box model so
for me a black box is something where
like the inner workings of the systems
are not clear to you so
completely hidden so for example like
the famous examples on our deep neural
networks right so nobody really knows
what's going on in your free layer lsdm
but even like a linear model with a bag
of words representation can be
considered a kind of black box because I
know no one who can really make sense
directly from 20,000 features
contributing to your prediction so it's
also something we probably want to
explain a little bit more so yeah I give
you a short outline what I'm doing so I
talked about the lime algorithm give you
a high-level overview how it works
what's the idea behind it how it applies
to the special case of text so there's a
more general idea you'll probably find
it in the paper and that's really nice
to read then we go because this is a
coding conference right we go to
examples show you how to implement with
scikit-learn in a simple way like the
basic idea and then we go to lime with
Eli 5 that's really really a nice thing
to visualize and to do really easy to
use and then of course sadly we have no
silver bullet in machine learning and
probably everywhere in life so there's
no free lunch also only anti data is
free lunch so if it fails often you
really have to know what you're doing
and how you look at your data and how do
you look at your model to make no
mistakes and build false trust in your
model so I'll show you how to make it
fail and how to prevent it sometimes so
let's look at a lime algorithm it was
introduced by reburial in 2016 it's a
really nice paper say it again look at
it read it it's also not hard to read
and the main idea is like you want to
explain the prediction like you want to
understand the prediction of a single
symbol X a certain sample of your
arbitrary black box model like you look
at one sample of your data and try to
understand why your model predicted a
certain prediction so what does the
abbreviation stand for
so the L is for locally so you you don't
care you probably have a highly
nonlinear model but you don't care for
all the nonlinearities you only want to
understand your model in the locality in
the neighborhood of your specific sample
then the I is for interpretable so you
you want an explanation it takes the
limitations of the user like the human
into account and it should deliver like
a qualitative understanding of your
model then we have the M for model
agnostic so the whole framework of line
is completely model agnostic you can use
any model you want you can explain deep
image classifiers or linear bag-of-words
models and then there is for
explanations here surprise yeah
so how does it work so the idea is you
generate a fake data set from your
picked sample you want to explain and in
the text case you just randomly sample
from your words like you have an email
and now you sample randomly at uniform
from the words and put them together in
the same order and that that you do have
5000 times and then you have 5000
different samples that all are close to
your sample you want to explain then you
get the predictions from your train
black box model on the fake data set
okay if these predictions you now train
so called white box model like the model
you want to use to explain your
complicated model like you take the X
like the fake dataset training data and
predictions of your black box model as
the labels the targets for your white
box model and then of course you use the
white box model to explain your black
box model and in the end you of course
want to know that's my white box model
learn something useful about my black
box month so is so it can happen that
the black box model is highly nonlinear
the neighborhood of your sample then you
probably aren't able to get a good white
box model for this sample or then you
see okay not approximating it well so
this is like a picture from the paper
that I have it in mind always when I
work with it because it's really good
visualization so you have like a highly
nonlinear model like they're pink and
blue it's kind of your decision regions
and you have your your fake samples and
you want to explain the prediction of
the strong red cross and the dashed line
is kind of your white box model okay
so let's go to code and look at some
example data so I picked a twenty
newsgroup data it's I guess some some
common block-post
data under it some new like write it I
guess I don't really know I wasn't able
to find out properly where this data
came from kind of legacy so we get it
from scikit-learn it's pretty easy then
everyone detect four of the classes like
a film Christianity computer graphics
and met and we want to do document
classification and then we look at the
sample and we will look at this sample
more often now because it's an
interesting sample so it's like from the
atheism class and someone is blaming the
Germans and some other one some other
guys playing a defending the Germans
kind of so interesting you probably
don't have to read it but I would point
to the interesting parts later and every
try in a black box classifier I picked
something kind of simple like we get
some and there's a features I never
trained an SVM with an RBF kernel so you
would so basically everyone would agree
this is probably highly in nonlinear and
you don't really know what's what's the
transformation really and it could be
could also be an Alice TM or something
else in the write-up on my github later
you will have to find how to do this
with cameras it's a little bit more
hacky and they refitted and we see that
okay we get like around 90% on the
tester thoughts not so bad right looks
okay ish for four classes okay then we
try to explain the prediction for this
sample we picked so this is the sample
again and now I show you how perturb
sample like a fake sample looks like
example looks like this right or I can
run the code again the small function is
basically just sampling randomly at
uniform a random number of words so
looks like this like this like this I
like this
so yeah and then we set up an explainer
model so does the simplified versions of
the real I'm algorithm implementing Eli
five to something smarter smarter in the
sampling and smarter in and the
explainer model but here I take like you
take a count vectorizer that you
basically have an interpretable
representation that is all your words
and then you select the K like the 10 in
this case best features by a univariant
test to make it understandable and limit
the complexity of your explanation this
is like the the real ly my room from the
paper does this by something called K
lasso so they do like a non univariant
feature selection there but it's not
supported in scikit-learn so don't try
to you and then we do logistic
regression as an interpretable model and
we weight is later in the fitting
process by the by the closeness of our
samples to the sample we want to explain
and then we get a lot of lot of
perturbed examples like 5000 here and
and get a predictions from our black box
model so and then we fit the explainer
model on the picture samples and the
predictions from the black box model
with the weights I can't
behind-the-scenes not so not so
interesting then we check how well do we
approximate it and looks okay ish like
we I will generate a new new test
dataset with a thousand samples and
checked how how well is our classifier
doing there it looks okay like 90
percent and then we do like extract the
features and the words from explainer
model he will get the vocabulary from
the contractor Iser and then the
important the 10 important words from
feature selection and then we look at
the explanation like we go through it
and visualize or like plot the plot
right the weights of the logistic
regression to the boards and we see like
okay it has the white box month 100%
atheism which is right and for
everything else it says basically okay
it's your 0 0 of course and we see here
the wait for some word so for example
her SGI has a pretty high weight or
article or CC and this is also already a
little bit suspicious so if you look at
Excel and the sample again we see like
SGI is obviously a domain of someone so
and article is something that means like
it was an answer to something often
obviously and the auto-life say it's
obviously a strong strong here not so
strong in this case but at least it is
in the 10 important features important
words so probably this is something we
don't want so obviously the model like
the black box model learned okay some
domains are talk about atheism more
often so I take just look at these
domains and it means it might work for
you but also might not work for you
because probably you want to use it for
something else you really want to
understand what is nicest
the block-post or whatever so we found
some leakage in our data set
yay but that you don't want to do it
with so I could learn because it's
little bit tedious not so tedious but
also not the smartest way to do it so
Eli 5 is really nice it's a Python
library of course you can get it on
github and on pip I guess it provides
insights to a lot of different models
also you can use it for XG boost or CRX
you'd if you want to use conditional
random fields provides interesting model
insights and it's also really extensible
it has much more multiple levels of
abstraction you can get a really low
level implementation of lime and or
really high level implementation of lime
for example for text that we're going to
use now and then provides nice
visualizations you can use multiple
different explainer models like decision
trees or whatever you think you can
understand and then it has better
sampling strategies than just sampling
uniform at random even though uniformed
rambling is uniform at random it's what
they suggested in the paper but you can
do smarter things and it's how it looks
like for the sample we saw above so we
have a text explainer from from the lr5
lime module and just set it up filled it
with the sample and you have to provide
some method that predicts a class
probability or class probabilities in
this case the predict problem method
from our text classifier a black box
model and then you use the show
predictions method and you get this nice
visualization in your tuba to notebook
so it has the high probability for
atheism and it really point points like
things a lot of like the email addresses
John life's a is obviously a really
strong atheist and then like a deuce or
probably educated people whatever and
for other things yeah you can so do you
see it uses more features like more
different words and a different
weighting I guess it's used
to buy grams instead of uni grams so and
now we see how it how do you fail I told
you sadly sadly it cannot do anything it
does not solve all your problems so you
have to be careful what interpretable
representation you use and what your
model is using to make predictions like
if you have a character based model then
obviously it's super hard to explain it
through the words like the individual
representation of the contactors in this
case or if you have some features that
are not directly related to your tokens
for example your document length then so
this is the example I'm going to show
you so you have we make up a simple
function that predicts always confuse it
like predicts computer graphics I guess
when it's at the length of the document
and the other case it predicts atheism
but we will see I always confuse it and
then yeah we look this is like all our
text so it should predict computer
graphics we will see and computer
graphics it is probably so we explained
it with this method we put here the
predict proper length method function
and we see it is basically doing random
you could because you are human you find
some patterns and things like oh yeah
Germany and anti-semitism okay
so probably this is a good explanation
or it's not so you don't see it here but
you can see it in the metrics so an Eli
5 provides you with two metrics you can
get from the metrics attribute so 1 is
the score like this is accuracy
in the neighborhood of your sample you
want to explain it's pretty low here and
then you get a mean
khumba Lightner divergence and they are
the lower the better so that's the mean
divergence of your class prediction
probabilities
and it's pretty high here so we would
probably say like oh this is a little
bit suspicious we probably looked
somewhere else
and try to find out what's going on
luckily that's the possibility to fix
this if you're suspecting that length of
your document is important so this is
like the big if if you know what what
could be your problem you probably can't
you could test it and try to fix it so
we can hack the the feature Iser of Eli
five and we put a little circuit learn
ready talk length feature extractor that
basically just adds two features and
make a future union with the con
vectorizer Eli five uses by default and
then we overwrite or set the vectorizer
parameter of the text explainer and do
the same again and then we see we get
another feature here the dot length it's
even a strong predictor for like a
strong explainer for our prediction and
we see also like the the metrics are
good metrics scores at one and versions
is that close to zero so perfect but
still there's some noise for whatever
reason I don't know yes so too long
didn't listen so my my takeaways
so inspect your models not only by
looking at a metric the validation
metrics so look at the model and like
it's some predictions so that the Eli
five paper also provides a method to go
global again like this method is only
local you have to look at certain
samples and pick smart and the paper
also shows how to do it like they
propose the method how to pick smart
samples so that you can understand your
model and go global again then lime can
help you to understand your model and
your data set of course like in the
leakages in the data set not in the
model right
and either five makes it really easy to
use and then the most important point is
when you're using lime you should
understand like the lenses you're
looking through when you use diagram
like what is your representation what is
the assumptions you have on your black
box model like using characters or using
different text derived features and
probably add them to your lime algorithm
with character based models really hard
to act because yeah and then never trust
an algorithm blindly that's made may be
the most important thing to take away
from yeah let's talk so I guess that's
it some short things about me I'm
writing a blog it depends on the
definition calm where you also will find
a write-up of this talk later this week
probably next week then my github
account where I will upload the slides
later and you can tweet at me at this
handler and that's it so how's the time
too quickly okay so we have time for
some discussions
I guess questions or discussions
yeah I was wondering that if your
algorithm spits out that it is focusing
on kind of the wrong things in your text
can you use that to guide your model
development through to not do that or
say as a discipline approach to doing
that I mean I mean depends on what your
problem is right if your dataset
I mean in this case let's go somewhere
well okay if we look at example again
here for example I would would suggest
probably like having a rags and remove
all email addresses and like things that
look like websites and then try it again
of course you can try if you if you see
your data set contains some leakage you
try to clean it and it's a little bit
more messy in the text domain and
probably in other domains yeah that's
this answer your question and the other
questions
okay well that's a tank to be again to
be yes
[Applause]